I have a question, which is
paparazzi's now using drones,
and they're sending drones over
while you guys are shooting in exotic locations,
they're sending drones to take pictures on the set
to try and create spoilers.
And that's incredibly annoying.
It's annoying 'cause I try to stay
away from the web unless it's pornography,
but--
(audience laughs)
But yeah, like Liam, for example,
it seems like that's a terrible invasion.
It's very, very, weird when you're
filming on a beach, and you hear a buzzing,
and you look up, and there's a drone
filming you as you're working.
And not only that, they were
live broadcasting it as we were working.
I mean, obviously, it's a huge spoiler.
It's disgraceful, but I don't know why
you'd wanna tell the end of the joke
halfway through the joke.
These are people who wanna watch the world burn.
Yeah, yeah.
Weird, weird, people.
Well, we have two of the shots
that just ruined the season for me,
and I'm gonna show them now,
'cause I just thought why should I be alone.
No, seriously, why should it just be me that suffers?
There's this shot right here that tells us
Chris Christie is
(audience cheering)
on a beach episode.
And then there's this one where
I find out that R2-D2 shows up.
(audience cheers)